I'm reviewing the skills you looked at
number one in your assignment number two
in the exercise of this time from
yesterday after our morning class so
having you look at this line you are
given all the sides in this right angled
triangle and I've asked for sine X that
you may like to recall that there's a
mnemonic device to remember for sine cos
of town
okay we say Toa
to help us remember what what is that
telling us okay so that's how you
remember it but what is it telling us
once you've remember that okay think
I've had about a few times sine tells us
about the ratio that's what we were
measuring out yesterday the race here
between now have a look here's the angle
that I'm interested in okay so the first
one that you should always identify is
the hypotenuse because the hypotenuse
doesn't care about where you are the
hypotenuse cares about what kind of
triangle you're in and where the angles
are so which one of these is the
hypotenuse now you know it's seven point
one and there are two ways you know it
okay number one it's a right angle
triangle so if you go to the right angle
you go opposite that you can see
opposite that this is the normal way you
see a right angle triangle right so
we're so used to thinking either
diagonal across but pay attention
sometimes you know mean teachers will
put the right angle in a fine spot so
pay attention that's one way of knowing
what's the other way of knowing which
one's the hypotenuse it must be the
longest side I can you have all three
here
so 4.35 9c 2.1 easy to compare so that's
the hypotenuse so it's going to be over
7.1 this is the opposite
which side is opposite the angle and you
can see I often actually draw a line
across strategy I'm looking the opposite
side five point six is gonna be the
number okay now some of you asked me uh
how many decimal places
should I give the question is not
provided for you and accuracy so if you
can give an exact answer that's kind of
better now that what I've just written
down that's an exact answer but it's a
bit messy we don't generally like
decimals and fractions to mix together
so what could I do to the numerator and
the denominator to get rid of all that
make whole numbers suggest many okay if
I take the numerator into it and
multiply by ten I'm actually gonna write
that as well I haven't changed the
fraction I'm just gonna be able to write
it without decimal points right 56 over
71 and I think that's that's it I don't
think you can simplify that any further
I'm happy to look on a question like
this if this was it and there was one
mark I think that'd be okay because the
most important thing about this is you
can identify opposite and have fun it's
not a fractions question it's a trick
question yeah but but this is clearly
better
if you gave the answers of decimals
elidio trickier because you've done
something that was not specified like
you've approximated when you could just
despite have given it exact yeah you
could I think this is fine but there's
no reason to go any further do extra
work that's what she said okay great
question so degrees is a measurement
about angles right so when you look at a
question like this a natural question to
be asked is well what is the size of the
angle and that would be some number of
degrees okay however read the question
carefully then I actually I'm not
actually asking you for the size of the
angle I'm interested in this right here
this opposite on hypotenuse ratio and if
you recall back when we did ratios and
rates ratios don't have years it's just
a number okay
so does that make sense that's it for
stop right let's come over here now
there's a bit of a trick involved we can
do the 10x first easily because 10x is
which pair sighs yeah it's opposite on
adjacent which are the two sides you
already know okay so can someone just
read off for me what's 10x very good
opposite over adjacent
but to get cosine to get cos of X you
can see for our acronym having two money
we need to Jason my punished but I don't
know what the hypotenuse is so am I
gonna do okay so this is why we had a
Pythagoras assignment right five squared
plus 12 scared that's 25 plus 144 that
means this is the square root of 169
which should give you 13 okay so once
you know the hypotenuse kha'zix is gonna
be which which pair of sides am I
looking at
adjacent on hypotenuse yeah
12 on 13 thank you very much . okay